[Musica]
buonasera a tutti
quando prendo la parola sono sempre un
po emozionato primo per rispetto a voi a
questo posto molto bello non sono
abituato a un contesto così prestigioso
ma soprattutto forse quello che mi
emoziona di più e che io rappresento gli
ultimi degli organismi dimenticati e
forse alcuni sorrideranno quando
capiranno chi chi mi riferisco
svilupperò un ragionamento molto breve e
forse citando la ragazza indiana che mi
ha preceduto che propone a di essere
pirata ecco forse questo è un discorso
più da pirata che da dal biologo di
un'istituzione
ecco siamo nella complessità
siamo nel mare della complessità al mare
a volte si presenta piatto a volte il
tempestoso e noi navighiamo
non possiamo sottrarci siamo nel mare
quel iceberg e non ci ricorda i ghiacci
polari che rischiamo di dimenticare ci
ricorda un'altra cosa
l'iceberg è la metafora della natura
l'iceberg sappiamo tutti che si vede
solo in parte la parte che emerge ma in
realtà quella parte che emerge è perché
sostenuta dalla parte sommersa per la
famosa spinta di archimede si sta a
galla perché c'è sotto qualcosa ecco io
voglio parlarvi di quello che ci sta
sotto a quello che vediamo
ecco è la parola chiave che userò molte
questo biodiversità termine abbastanza
recente è nato negli anni 80 ed è stato
coniato per sintetizzare in un unico
concetto un'idea nuova che la scienza
aveva messo a punto cioè la grande
diversità che c'è all'interno della
specie
noi siamo la stessa specie abbiamo occhi
diversi colori diversi numeri di scarpe
diverse sangue diverso quindi
all'interno di una specie c'è diversità
ci sono specie diverse in questo
giardino io prima mi son divertito
controllato quanti alberi ce ne sono
tanti
e poi c'è la diversità di ambienti
abbiamo il giardino il campo il santo
già il monte dell'abbazia queste sono
tre livelli di diversità di cui dobbiamo
essere consapevoli e si può misurare la
biodiversità certo possiamo misurarla
quante specie esistono allora alfa da
oggi la scienza sa delle cose e sa che
ci sono 2 milioni di specie
stiamo parlando dai grandi mammiferi
alle alle alghe ai batteri questo numero
queste specie hanno un nome e cognome
sono state organizzate in categorie
queste categorie riflettono l'evoluzione
cioè il processo lunghissimo per cui la
vita è diventata sempre più efficiente
sempre più capace di assorbire energia
sfruttare le risorse e stare in simbiosi
il concetto di evoluzione e troppo
spesso associato solo alla competizione
in realtà la competizione esiste ma è
una parte minima rispetto alla
collaborazione gli organismi sono
cooperativi lo scontro è l'ultima ratio
sempre comunque quindi di specie ne
esistono due milioni note alla scienza
dicevo con nome e cognome poi gli
esperti non sono concordi se dichiarare
stimare che ce ne siano altri 2 milioni
e fanno quattro quindi avremo metà della
mia diversità da scoprire
oppure 20 il che vuol dire oggi ne
conosciamo solo il 10 per cento oppure
100 milioni che vuol dire che la gran
parte del lavoro ci resta da fare no
ecco però al di là del numero quello che
è importante è capire è che abbiamo un
patrimonio gigantesco frutto di milioni
di anni di evoluzione e che ha visto che
il problema oggi lo stiamo creando noi e
sulla nostra sulle nostre spalle sulla
nostra coscienza
c'è un modo che in cui possiamo
immaginare la vita
diciamo un mosaico prendiamo un mosaico
se lo guardiamo da vicino abbiamo delle
tessere una affianco all'altra colori
diversi o colori simili potrebbero
essere le spese però se ci allontaniamo
man mano un mosaico lo capiamo se stiamo
a distanza quindi anche la vita sulla
terra
la si osserva bene se si analizzano i un
po più da lontano no quindi però questo
mosaico e mosaico in cui le tessere sono
fluide sono in movimento sono in
relazione l'ecologia è la scienza delle
relazioni un'altra parola chiave la
biosfera quando gli astronauti i primi i
primi uomini che volarono veramente
lontano dalla terra poterono per la
prima volta guardare dicevano cavanda
avanti l'arancia blu il pianeta terra è
meraviglioso c'è l'acqua ci sono i
boschi e si vede anche da lontano allora
la biosfera è quella pelle vivente che
circonda il il mondo di cui noi facciamo
parte
un altro concetto che si usa molto in
ecologia è la rete ecologica il fatto
che siamo tutti questi questi che questo
sistema complesso e ha dei legami a
delle relazioni quindi immaginatevi un
reticolo enorme di cui scegliete la
casella possiamo metterci anche noi e
siamo legati qual è il problema che se a
questa rete noi cominciamo a tagliare i
nodi se questa rete cominciamo a
danneggiare i legami avremo meno
connettività avremo meno resistenza
avremo meno resilienza allora io
propongo che per proteggere la natura
dobbiamo cominciare dai tagli ultimi
nessuno deve rimanere indietro quando si
salva la natura non ci sono tutto è
importante tutto è fondamentale anche
gli ultimi gli ultimi farò un discorso
capirete molto terra terra sono sotto i
nostri piedi anche cominciò da questo
strano insetto un coleottero
potrei citare kafka che fa un libro
bellissimo
la metamorfosi in cui tale gregorio
samsa si sveglia una mattina ed è
diventato sente tutto duro è diventato
un
uno scarabeo diciamo è un libretto molto
veloce e molto denso comunque io vi
parlo invece di questo strano scarabeo
che profuma di pesca veramente in una
cosa incredibile è che si chiama anche
osmo there was there ma vuol dire dalla
bella e profumata
si chiama eremita perché generalmente se
ne trovavano pochissimi gli scienziati
gli disse ruba questo sta sempre da solo
in realtà sta da solo perché il suo
ambiente è costituito da grandi alberi
in questo giardino non ci sono alberi da
eremita sono troppo giovani ha bisogno
di piante centenarie
voi capite che il nostro ambiente ormai
di questi alberi mia pochi e quindi
questa specie è andata ad estinzione o è
rimasta solo nei posti molto naturali
l'unione europea lo ha protetto proprio
perché rare minacciata comunque un
castagneto un grande gelso deve esserci
un albero che ha delle cavità perché
perché in queste cavità la femmina
tratta dal maschio che fa su questo
profumo meraviglioso arriva depone le
sue uova dalle uova escono le larve e
larve si trovano dentro un buco un buco
che ha un po di segatura di fogliame
questo materiale molto povero e questa
larghezza comincia a mangiare la
segatura e materiale poverissimo non è
che se noi ci danno un piatto di
segatura anche se sei un designer del
cibo non è che andiamo tante la invece
loro ce la fanno perché ce la fanno
perché la larva è a sua volta un
ecosistema a degli organismi simbionti
parola che altri hanno già citato la
simbiosi ana è una parola bellissima poi
anch'io mi chiedo sempre se siamo in
simbiosi perché la simbiosi e
reciprocità non è solo una relazione la
simbiosi è una relazione in cui tutti e
due vincono win win
non si dice questa larva ha la capacità
di in 23 anni diventa adulta e viene
fuori questo bellissimo scarabeo allora
come aiutare questo questo organismo a
rischio d'estinzione qui mi sono portato
questo cassone
che non è un per la raccolta
differenziata si apre ci posso andare
tanto il microfono comunque è una bella
cassa che noi attendiamo ci mettiamo la
nostra segatura fino a questa altezza e
ci mettiamo anche le larve di questi
insetti davvero rari e quest'anno grazie
a questo progetto che è un progetto
coordinato dalla regione emilia romagna
che ha un'idea semplice ma di successo
quest'estate nel colle dell'abbazia dove
abbiamo messo queste casse con le larve
allevate in cattività per la prima volta
dopo tanto tempo sono tornati a volare
nelle notti d'estate all'abbazia questi
grossi bellissimi coleotteri allora
parlando con gli amici quando dicevo
dobbiamo proteggere gli sfortunati di
definisco così questi animali del cavolo
e allora uno mi ha detto ma guarda che
non sei il solo a dire sta cosa cioè
altri se ne sono occupati tanto tempo fa
mi ha suggerito di leggere nella nella
genesi che è una parte importante del
vecchio testamento
il momento topico quando dio chiama noè
che è giusto e gli dice senti la mia
creazione era un'opera blu al digerisco
è una gran creazione il problema è
l'uomo
devo rifare l'uomo ma non è che adesso
mi rimetto a fare tutta la biodiversità
allora tu statua famiglia e tu prepari
un arca in quest'arca mettiamo la tua
famiglia e poi gli dà le istruzioni e
gli dice devi prendere sette animali
delle spese pure perché gli ebrei
dividevano pure impuri delle specie che
sono pure ne prendi sette coppie e degli
animali impuri ne prendi una coppia
maschio e femmina e anche degli uccelli
ne prende 7 copie poi questa cosa io
mando ti do sette giorni era abbastanza
non scherzava
ti do sette giorni e poi 40 giorni di
pioggia 40 giorni giorno e notte un
meteo pazzesco e e cosa succede che
ovviamente non è salva
tutti gli animali che ordinatamente
prima erano saliti e poi troveranno il
mondo privo dell'uomo bene uno potrebbe
dire ma noi fa tutto questo perché è
finito il diluvio avrà bisogno di
mangiare avrò bisogno di far lavorare
degli animali invece no perché se
prendete sempre il vecchio testamento
alle viti co dove danno dove si danno
indicazioni su cose buone cose non è
buono ci sono un mucchio di animali che
non sono per niente buoni anzi per gli
ebrei sono abominevoli abominevoli non
se ne mangerà ma fanno proprio schifo
però dio dà ordine anno è di salvare
tutto e perché fa questo perchè non sa
che il mondo che verrà
quello dopo il diluvio avrà bisogno di
tutta la biodiversità
dunque una società di più di duemila
anni fa
no diceva che era abominevole una cosa
ma al tempo stesso la conservava almeno
idealmente quindi questo concetto
secondo me molto appropriato a questa
epoca e ecco qui c'è un bel lombrico lo
avete riconosciuto da dire che è un
lombrico non so c'è la gara tra la fico
non so cos'è più inutile di un verme se
vi viene in mente un esempio dopo la
prossimo talk ea cui mi invitano io
parlerò di quello era venuto in mente la
mosca cieca mosca molesta che poteva
essere adatta la biodiversità del suolo
lan già citata e degli altri amici è la
nostra noi siamo siamo tanti perché c'è
l'agricoltura è tutta l'agricoltura la
villa romana era in questa zona perché
questo è un terreno fertile ma è un
terreno fertile perché ci sono dei cicli
naturali che l'hanno resa aperti la
fertilità l'uomo la può conservare ma
non la può fare se la fa c'è dietro un
trucco e quel trucco e la co2 che
e non vogliamo non possiamo più
permetterci allora la vera fertilità
viene dalla vita viene
dall'organizzazione dei sistemi naturali
che anche in un contesto coltivato
possono essere esaltati e produrre cose
che ci interessano cioè prodotti buoni
di salute e e giusti
allora anche qui apro un libro del 1881
io c'ho la versione del 1882
si chiama la formazione del terreno
vegetale per effetto del lavoro dei
lombrichi di charles darwin e che si
interroga si accorge che non c'è nessun
trattato sui lombrichi lui aveva capito
benissimo nella sua bellissima residenza
inglese aveva capito quanto lavorano i
lombrichi lombrichi sono degli
stakanovisti che anche i giapponesi ci
fanno un baffo perché a questi non
scherzano e cosa dice ve la faccio breve
alla fine di questo trattato dice che è
stupendo pensare che tutto il terreno
vegetale di una distesa erbosa e passate
passerà di nuovo ogni tot anni per il
corpo dei lombrichi l'aratro che è una
delle più antiche utili invenzione
dell'uomo prima che esso esistesse la
terra già regolarmente a rate continua a
essere adattata i lombrichi contenuti si
può mettere in dubbio che vi siano molti
altri animali che abbiano avuto una
parte tanto importante nella storia del
mondo quanto quella avuto da esseri da
questi essere dall'organismo così basso
allora il signor darwin nella mia nel
mio pantheon e molto in alto e dicendo
così mi ha proprio sdoganato a sto punto
io faccio un elogio sperticato all'om
briko ea tutti i piccoli
anche qui lombrico è la specie bandiera
il simbolo di una grande biodiversità
che è il suolo la fertilità del suolo è
la cosa più importante che da cui chi si
occupa di suolo deve tendere c'è un
conto alla rovescia questo conto che è
partito
siamo all'interno di un unico mondo
globalizzato abbiamo mescolato portato
specie di qua di la destra e sinistra
abbiamo fatto un casino pazzesco e la
biodiversità sta tremando pensate che in
italia tutti i gruppi sceglietene uno
uccelli farfalle anfibi e il 30 per
cento sono tutti a rischio di estinzione
un terzo però stanno partendo degli
effetti domino per cui specie comunismo
il passero che ce n'erano tanti fino a
20 anni fa erano tantissimi passirio
abitava bazzano quando facevo venivo a
monteveglio ce n'erano di schiacciati un
casino
i moscerini i moscerini che durante
l'estate che ha una certa età più di 40
si ricorderà nei fanali delle macchine
ci voleva bisognava lavarli adesso voi
fate dei centinaia di chilometri
moscerini ne trovate pochi questa
profonda subito la trasformazione
perdita di pezzi e ha un effetto domino
abbastanza imprevedibile
gli stessi scienziati non sanno bene che
cosa succederà certo llamo dei pezzi ma
non sappiamo cosa non funzionerà
sicuramente bene non fa e quindi dopo
l'esempio da pirata di del povero
lombrico del povero e profumatissimo
però bisogna dirlo scarabeo eremita
finisco lasciando la chiusura una
persona che stimo molto che è indiana
che è vandana shiva che è una scienziata
è un ambientalista che siccome c'è
sempre questo ricatto morale quando tu
vuoi proteggere qualcosa qualcuno ti
dice sì però c'è l'uomo non vorrai mica
opporre un ambiente ai bisogni dell'uomo
e lei che di questi conflitti ne ha già
visti abbastanza risponde che l'unica
maniera di venire incontro ai crescenti
bisogni umani è proprio la protezione
della biodiversità perché finché non ci
occuperemo dei lombrichi degli uccelli
delle farfalle non saremmo neppure in
grado di occuparci delle persone questa
idea in base alla quale la specie umana
può venire incontro alle proprie
necessità
solo eliminando
tutte le altre a un assunto sbagliato si
basa su non vedere che il tessuto della
vita ci unisce tutti e fino a che punto
viviamo in interazione intento ed
interdipendenza e con questo finito
[Applauso]